foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones season
8 video alright my friends here we are
once again with another video where we
find out exactly how some of Game of
Thrones biggest actors felt about the
show's ending if you saw my recent video
on Varys then you already know how he
felt about his awful exit from the show
well in this video you're gonna see how
our old friends Jamie and Cersei
Lannister felt about their death at the
end of Game of Thrones one of them
actually thought their ending was very
fitting while the other one was
devastated when they found out what
their final scene would be you're gonna
see that one of them thought their
character should have been given a very
different ending like I have said in my
other videos the further and further we
get away from Game of Thrones ending the
more insight we will get into how each
of the Game of Thrones actors really
felt about David and Dan's writing now
before you find out which one of them
hated their ending I have to let all of
you know about this amazing new offer
I'd like to thank the sponsor of this
video Morgan and Morgan Morgan and
Morgan is America's largest injury law
firm with over 900 attorneys operating
in all 50 states Morgan and more organ
has modernized the injury law process by
making it incredibly easy to submit a
claim submitting a claim for an injury
doesn't have to be a difficult process
with Morgan and Morgan there's no need
for you to visit law offices and sit
through long consultations you can
submit a claim and have a lawyer review
your case with only eight clicks on your
phone plus you could submit your case
details sign contracts upload documents
and medical records all from your cell
phone and you can even text your
attorney and legal team throughout the
duration of your case Morgan and Morgan
will fight to get you the best results
and their fee is free you only pay if
they win no upfront costs or sign up
fees either with Morgan and Morgan you
don't just get a lawyer assigned to your
case you get a dedicated legal team
complete with case investigators
paralegals and customer case Specialists
all focused on maximizing Your
settlement Morgan and Morgan has over 4
000 support staff available at any hour
to help with your case contacting a
personal injury attorney is a no-brainer
and it costs you nothing unless they win
don't overthink it and take action to
protect your writes and Morgan and
Morgan will fight to get you the
compensation you deserve if you're ever
injured in an accident you could submit
a claim at
www.fortherpeople.com talking Thrones or
by dialing pound law that's pound 529 on
your phone you don't want to miss out on
this amazing offer once again I have to
thank Morgan and Morgan for sponsoring
today's video
foreign
now as you all know Jamie and Cersei
Lannister are very high on the list of
who had the worst ending on the show not
only did millions of fans hate how Jaime
ran right back to Cersei in the end but
they also hated the way in which they
died if Jamie and Cersei Were Meant to
die together they should have at least
been given a better death considering
they were under direct Fire by a damn
dragon now although Lena was and still
is an amazing actress I think it's safe
to say that most of us hated Cersei
Lannister after everything she had done
over the eight seasons of the show I
think cersei's fate should have been
more horrific I mean let's be honest
here we should have seen Cersei
Lannister get burned alive by Danny's
dragon that would have been a satisfying
death for someone like the evil Cersei
Lannister she did not deserve to get to
die in the arms of Jaime while we saw so
many of our beloved friends get
slaughtered in so many different ways
now I think what really upset me the
most about Jaime's ending was how they
went back on everything he said to
Brienne during their amazing scene all
the way back in season three
tell me if your precious friendly
commanded you to kill your own father
and stand by one of thousands of men
women and children Panda life would you
have done it
Jamie running back to Cersei was one
thing but for him to ruin so much of his
development with one sentence as
unforgivable I know I wasn't alone with
my feeling of disgust after seeing
Jaime's final conversation with his
brother
if not for yourself if not for her and
for every one of the million people in
that City innocent or otherwise to be
honest I never really cared much for
them
innocent or otherwise now before I go
all the way back down that road again
let me show you what the actors had to
say about their final moments on the
show as you all know Game of Thrones was
known for the unexpected and absolutely
devastating deaths of some of our
favorite characters no one was
guaranteed safety in Game of Thrones and
that's what kept the viewers on the edge
of their seats one such example is that
of Nikolai Costa waldow and Lena
headey's characters which left many fans
disappointed however Nikolai actually
defended his character's ending and
stated that it was beautiful in season 8
after Jaime finally reunites with
Brienne he leaves her behind to rescue
his sister from the wrath of Daenerys
Targaryen unfortunately their reunion
was short-lived and the duo succumbed to
their deaths in each other's arms as
Daenerys burned down King's Landing in
its red key while the death of their
characters have received a mixed
reactions from the fans Nikolai couldn't
have been happier with his ending even
though fans would have loved to see
Jaime and Brienne together at the end he
believes James me dying in cersei's arms
was the best ending for his character a
Reddit user found an interview of the
actor discussing their final scene where
he stated it made sense for me Jaime has
always been dedicated to his sister she
was pregnant after all and on her own so
of course he's going to go back and try
to help her it made complete sense to me
that ending I thought was romantic I was
quite sure that a lot of the fans would
be very upset that he didn't stay with
Brianne but I thought it was beautiful
now what are your thoughts on Jaime and
cersei's ending should he have gotten
his happily ever after with Brienne or
was it absolutely fitting for him to go
back to his sister I don't think either
should have happened I think Jaime
should have died in Winterfell defending
Bran Stark I think that would have been
an amazing full circle moment for his
character when you consider he tried to
murder bran in the very first episode
now let's see what his fictional sister
had to say because she did not agree
with his sentiment while Nikolai was all
for the ending his on-screen sister and
ex-lover does not seem to share the same
thoughts during her interview with with
the Observer Lena stated that whenever
she gets the chance to sit down with the
show's writers she will tell them that
Cersei wanted a better death Haiti went
on to state that she was gutted with how
her character story ended but understood
that there was no way the show could
have made everyone happy after reading
this we now know that not even she was
happy about it she said obviously you
dream of your death you could go in any
way on that show so I was kind of gutted
but I just think they couldn't have made
everyone happy no matter what they did I
think there was going to be a big come
down from that climb so as you can see
not only did cersei's ending leave her
feeling gutted but she also hopes to see
David and Dan again so she can let them
know that Cersei deserved A better
ending now we know Cersei Danny Varys
and even Jon Snow were not satisfied
without Game of Thrones ended their
final season I believe Lena was more
than upset not only did cersei's Death
suck but she was basically wasted for
the whole final six episodes of the show
all Cersei did was stand around looking
over the city while sipping on her damn
line I think Cersei gave us way too many
amazing moments over the seasons for her
to just sit on the sidelines during the
show's ending she should have had
something else up her sleeve I don't
think she should have just stood around
crying while the red cape fell down
around her I don't think Cersei would
have actually done that I always thought
that she might run back to casterly rock
or maybe even somewhere else but
unfortunately we got what we got what
did all of you think about Cersei
Lannister's final scene was there
anything you would have done differently
leave me all your thoughts down below
I'm interested in hearing what you have
to say once again I have to thank all of
you for always showing love to my videos
I hope everyone has a great day make
sure you subscribe because there's a lot
more videos heading your way I'll see
you again very soon bye
hmm
[Music]
foreign